foreign
[Music]
if you could go anywhere in the whole
world where would you go I always wanted
to be part of something bigger
love that answer something that lasts
that means something something more
important than life yeah
[Music]
it's written in this
[Applause]
school I had money I would only spend it
on things that were fun you know not
boring things like taxes I'm just
wanting for everyone to party forever
[Applause]
when I first moved to LA Signs and all
the doors said no actors or dogs allowed
I changed that
and now y'all ready for something
different
you know we have to do you have to
redefine the form map those dreams and
print them into history look up and say
Eureka I'm not alone
stop
I'm in so much trouble Manny
you have to leave now
you thought this town needed you
it's bigger than you
that's the most magical place in the
world
[Applause]
let's hang up who wants to see me fight
a snake
hell yeah
my son sacrificed his life to save me
are not a gift but a curse
born out of Rage
[Music]
all right
this Loose Cannon needs to be locked
down
for innocent people start getting hurt
it's been asleep for five thousand years
you find us a cell that can hold them
we'll take care of the breath who's on
the team
I didn't bring a passport we don't need
passports
to the Justice Society
we're here to negotiate your peaceful
peace
I'm not peaceful
nor do I Surrender
here we go
I kneel before no one
[Music]
come here to see Justice
of exact Revenge
[Music]
I never said I was a hero
[Music]
you believe you are not worthy
fate does not make mistakes
[Music]
you can be the destroyer of this world
[Music]
or you can be its savior
no one knows how it starts
but when the fear begins
when the paranoia takes over
makes people do terrible things
good morning as you can see some of you
have chosen to stay home today given
what's been happening
there's something going around some
scary internet character that tells you
to kill people it made this kid stab his
own mother there's a lot of people
freaking out about it nobody knows what
it actually is
foreign
yeah like in my house well what is it
[Music]
we've been getting calls about it all
night
how are we supposed to protect our
family
my parents can't see it but when I try
to tell them what I saw just makes it
more hysterical
thank you
Dad can we start over
we can just sit down and I'll talk it
out together
I'm just trying to protect him
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I see you yeah
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
I present to you
the eighth wonder of the world
[Music]
the one and only being
[Applause]
hello pups
Keepers and almost real oh
[Music]
turn around let me get a look at you
I will be right here when you get back
Pinocchio is running around loose
without a conscience can you imagine the
trouble he's gonna get into wouldn't
want that on my conscience everybody
who's anybody who wants to be a somebody
that I want to be real why on Earth
would you want to be real when you can
be famous
[Music]
laughs
[Music]
okay we should have been home by now
he won't be a puppet anymore
that's for sure
[Music]
be brave
truthful not selfish
[Music]
you will always be my real boy
a lie can really change a person panops
what's happening Jiminy looks like some
sort of fairy magic
kinda on the nose if you ask me
[Music]
come on you can do this
we are outgoing the only way to catch
this crew is in the ACT you're going New
York turn up the issue I'm dying to give
you the problem you practically begging
for is the opinion of the department
that James Knight wasn't hunting bank
robbers he be robbing thanks that might
be rough on the edges but he's a good
cop This Crew is tight they move like a
team you got a theory or roads lead back
to a businessman because by winner
I hope I'm not uh interrupting what can
I do you for yeah a lot of X Pros I had
a couple of them for a message
do anything about that not to the best
my recollection think real hard
FBI CIA HF all have open cases on Winner
and two city cops from La walk in here
and they think they're gonna handle this
hey
served in the Marines seems to have some
disciplinary hearing every year I was
thinking but it would try your way in
the night is the most dangerous piece on
the board hello [ __ ] and strike when
you least expect it
oh please are you uh trying to be funny
no I can take you out whenever I want
wherever I want
how can you be at the wrong place at the
right time all the time
[Music]
[Applause]
trick or treat mother
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
wish I could be
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if the task is not completed with an
acceptable parameters your daughter will
die
task complete
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Eileen
Eileen get up save Roger my husband
[Music]
what did you do to me
why are you doing this
there's my daughter
calm down
[Music]
okay
she still can't say it
there you go that's exactly what I just
said
getting married you are who's the lucky
lady I don't know yet what do you mean
I'm gonna arrange marriage my assisted
marriage that's what we're calling these
days What About Love you're going to
love the person you're with
syndrome
so your ideas for your next film I could
follow my childhood friend to marry a
stranger chosen by his parents my big
fat arranged wedding me the parents
first love contractually huh
Mo here vote the Matchmaker no photos no
no photos yet you're thinking with the
Lulu you need to be thinking okay
the food chain
and any vices I should know about
drinking smoking dogging
no dogs no pets no the doggy means
something just don't cats are okay got
me got news I got
what I really like her hi hi love at
first Skype how do you feel about
possibly moving to London
she's fine with it it's a very
Multicultural place
[Music]
the wedding's in Pakistan you're still
fully signed up to this
you're forgetting I've seen it work
maybe you should focus on your own
choices you actively search how anyone
who is wrong no one can get close to you
am I just half the person when I'm not
with the man is that what you think
oh
you know why the prophet said Paradise
lies at the mother's feet there is no
love
greater than a mother's love for her
child your happiness that's all that
matters
we all need other people there's no
weakness in that
how the party starts
to think that I was scared of being with
the wrong person but now I realize that
I'm scared of being with the right
person
I've been very lucky to have them as
nervous actually they've become like
family to me since your father left for
that teenage tour she's 35 exactly
movies are dreams
[Music]
but you never forget
Tammy
[Music]
the lights change how everything looks
it's hard to find our house harsh is the
dark house with no lights
in this family it's the scientists
versus the artists
[Music]
Sammy's on my team takes after me
what kind of movie You're Gonna Make
You dismissed what he does it's playful
or imaginative
could afford to be a little encouraging
she should have been that concert piano
player but she got in her heart is what
you got you can't just love something
you also have to take care of it it's
more important than your hobby can you
stop calling it a hobby
[Music]
you always have to be the center of
attention stop sounding at her that has
been nothing but disrespect from you I'm
Your Mother
family hot
it'll tear you into
you stopped making movies that'll break
your mother's heart I don't know what to
do anymore you do what your heart says
you have
what was your favorite part
[Music]
we're in a bit of a predicament
[Music]
we need to clear our names oh that's
something
it was killed because of something that
he had seen as an organization we want
to rule the world
rule the world
you get people to help us out it's the
only hope that we have to get out of
this situation let's hope this goes well
things have got more complicated
okay you want to start this
drink's on me
literally
where this came from
today
Amsterdam rated R did someone slap you
Bert because you have a red mark on your
face I got swag I got punched oh no no
no only in theaters October 7th
what was that that is an ambulance
that was a car tire
I have no idea what that was
New York City did we just move here I
think we did you think Josh is gonna be
okay
this is my crocodile why I take good
care of him
gosh time to wake up come on
he's not dangerous he's Crocodile he's
just lonely like me hey you awake yet
you can't talk but you can sing at the
top of the world tonight
when no one ever it has to hide
everybody get out of here there's a
crocodile in the house
this could not be happening we have a
crocodile living in her attic
that was totally awesome
the city must do something
do you realize how different things have
been since I met him
hunting into
changed everything for me not just for
me for you too
I've been shaking I love it when you go
crazy
we have to show people that they don't
have to be afraid
you got a crocodile on a motorcycle
there's nothing wrong with me
baby nothing holding me back
You Ever Had A Night Like This ever in
your entire life
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Sheila hi hi I'm uh I'm Gary
gonna get it
thank you
cheers mate
that was kind of weird oh not really
I have got to come clean with you I'm
from the future
wait I'm I'm sorry I'm a little confused
so how much do you use the tanning
machine oh no it's not a tan machine
it's a time machine
try it it's fun I spent the entire week
with you this night seven times in a row
[Music]
wait what'd you do with the other you
from the past
Have You Ever Had A Night Like This ever
in your entire life
just wanted to change a couple things to
make you more perfect this never
happened with old Gary if you erase the
pain you erase the person what exactly
did you change about me I have this
ability to take your pain away it's not
yours to take away Sheila it came from a
good place Gary yeah so did gender
reveal parties
started as an as an accident
and this time I am gonna make it work
a real Sophie's Choice kind of decision
now isn't it I love it when you make
that joke what what
[Applause]
you didn't want to go somewhere more
meaningful like I don't know like to
kill Hitler well I did take out Smithson
who exactly
you can't just show up here with no
warning what's wrong does something
happen
yes
Nicholas has come to live with me and
he's improving but he's still a little
fragile it's the way he came to see me
you're blaming me for what happened
he's different from the others what
makes you say that why don't you answer
me I do answer you the look in his eye
is disturbing she wants to turn us
against one another
our family I feel like a complete
failure if I'm like this it's your fault
what have I done what's my fault haven't
I always done everything for you I have
the right to reinvent my life it is my
life
[Music]
everything okay at home yeah
everything's fine
[Music]
I banish thee from Sailor forever
[Music]
they were right to fear thee
magic has a way of uniting
happy 16th birthday child
I have a gift from my favorite customers
Legend has it it's on the 16th birthday
that a witch gets her powers
Gilbert where did you get that candle we
have to get out of here the witch it'll
be here any seconds the book is alive he
woke up
if we intend to live past Sunrise we
have to steal this so whoa whoa wait can
we talk about this
Not freak out the provincial Maniac
obsessed with getting revenge on Salem
so
for sale
we should get some salt why so it tastes
better when they eat us
[Music]
so far
[Music]
that's not Six Feet Under
I am a good zombie
special guest in the audience tonight
legendary record executive Mr Clyde
Davis
Poison's gone what you start the show
tonight no talking back I'm Your Mother
[Applause]
there's a boy I know he's the one I
dream of what's your name again Whitney
Elizabeth Houston
my dream
sing what I want to sing be how I want
to be
friends with every heartbeat
we just be an audience as I can
uh common criticism of you your music
isn't black enough look I don't know how
to sing black and I don't know how to
sing white either I know how to sing
I might have just heard the greatest
voice of Her generation
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I know that change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
if I learned anything from meeting a
princess on a billboard is that
sometimes you just have to take a leap
let's start our new life
the place will feel like home you'll see
it's all part of the adventure that's
not an adventure that's a landfill a
land filled with Adventure
Robert congratulations oh it's what they
call her Fixer-Upper yes once your
peasants have dug out the moat and added
a turret and a balcony from which you
can sing I see it now okay
Melvina Monroe I would have sold you
this house but I deal in slightly more
upscale
in andalasia the hardest part of life is
finding your happily ever after this
world's very different and this world is
not to your liking then you must change
it
I wish Jumping Jelly stick wait how am I
talking I wish
I wish for a Fairytale life and it's all
gone terribly wrong or terribly right
and the last stroke of twelve nothing
will be as it was before
[Music]
foreign
what have you done
that's wicked wicked good
[Music]
to all of us to all of us
[Music]
we need to be my wife
[Music]
this love is all-consuming
I pity people who don't know what it
feels like to be
come with me just you and I he's trying
to destroy our marriage without hiding
in the lies you know nothing about being
married telling me what I'm supposed to
think about it
he was always in your life in our lives
[Music]
the United States stands for an idea
whose time is now Ronald Reagan will win
tonight what a schmuck
I think I want to be an artist when I
grow up I'm going to be an artist if you
want to be nothing's going to stop you
you're going to college go have dinner
with Kings if he places right
I really like your stickers my
stepfather gave them to me he's in the
Air Force that's so cool
how dare you
are you not to associate with him again
what do you mean why
I think you know what I mean
my parents are sending me to my
brother's school it's heavy
in this institution you can be anything
you want to be it won't be because of a
handout it'll be because you earned your
way there
was bugging you what is sometimes kids
say bad words about the black kids who's
there somebody from my old school
did they ever come to your house what'd
you do when that happens obviously
nothing of course you think that's small
my mother yeah Mommy came over here we
didn't have much why'd she come here
because I wanted to kill her that's why
it's about a soldiers and sometimes they
go out looking for Jews they hated us
then they still hate us
so I got on the boat and we came over
here to America the land of dreams
you just wanted to be like you I want
you to be a whole lot better than me
life is unfair be thankful when you get
a leg up you make the most of your break
and do not look back all my hopes with
you and your brother after my whole life
[Music]
[Applause]
next time those Schmucks are anything
bad about those kids we're gonna say
something
it's gonna be a match okay firm
handshake okay give me a hug
foreign
[Music]
what happened to you
I don't remember
before I knew you I didn't really know
what I wanted in life
and then I met you and I feel like I'm
going somewhere
I don't even know where but I just know
I want to go there with you
you ready to tell us what happened to
you
were you alone
sir don't remember
I think something's really wrong with
her
what I'm trying to say is
you're my person Ruth
what is wrong with you
I love you but people change
Someday I'm Gonna Change
maybe you loved that new version
and maybe you won't
okay
it's just I haven't been feeling like
myself
myself
[Music]
I
miss you
[Music]
love mommy
say bye-bye hi Mommy
[Music]
honey Aisha's here I don't want you to
feel overwhelmed okay here's any number
you need including her therapist thank
you
from the sky just work hard to keep it
where are you from
South Africa
Senegal oh we got a winner
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
do not ignore the signs
you have you paid me but I am odd you
think Ash is just laying around I am a
mother too I thought so
[Music]
I miss my country
every day
you're gonna be okay
I wish I knew what's happening to me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
last night you made the unfortunate
mistake of breaking into my ancestral
home
don't worry this is not an execution
where's the sport in that good luck
body let us go why did they wish us luck
what's that
a fox hunt
so what are the hunting
people are going to find out about this
about what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this Halloween you can't escape the
shark the terror of
werewolf by night tonight it is every
Hunter for themselves good luck I'll be
rotting for you
but one of you is a monster
masquerading as one of our own
can't wait to find out what breed of
evil you are
[Music]
[Applause]
please don't do this
death is coming for you
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s believe in Paranormal Activity
Spirits a demonologist
no I don't well I do because I'm gonna
be playing one
Clayton hey Donald what's up Suddenly I
didn't know they were going this way on
this part I sincerely hope they at some
point this year you do work I'd like to
really like you man they want you back
in for a call back on Monday yes
I need this roll
I saw your ad on the internet about the
demonologist
[Music]
I need you to trust me
while the ritual will have very little
chance of success
ritual
[Laughter]
it's a human blood shall we get started
David's coming in any forms
I need to be great or else they're going
to give the role to Donald
you told me you already had this spot
you're scared I am not scared
are you out of your mind
what are you hiding from
here
I've been waiting for you my whole life
[Music]
Laura
are you okay
[Music]
I had an overdose
come home I could look after you
everything here is just like old times
you're the first person I've seen who
actually looks like they've got any
older since I left
doesn't anyone die around here
I knew I recognized you
your mother she's very popular in the
village
[Music]
[Applause]
mum I've missed that word
say it again
this isn't how I remember it things
change you haven't I never hurt you
remember when you threatened to take my
mouth shut
I want to try to get past the past
of course
[Music]
your mom asked me to make sure you
didn't leave do something out there
something against God
something
changed your mother and change the
village
[Music]
what's happening to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's something I want you to see you up
for it yeah
[Music]
we'll call him Blue Back
gropers can live until their 70s old and
wise
they live in the same place most of
their life
I don't tend to leave
the only way to make sure he's safe is
keep him a secret
what's going on the entry to the Bay is
too shallow you need to dredge The Reef
these fish are meant to be protected how
can they do this man
stealing from our future you and your
mum really think you can stop this don't
you
those men they wanted to kill him
what if he doesn't come back
but I found it the same again
my name is Abby Jackson and I'm 15 years
old
I've been studying this space since I
was eight
the whole Reef will be gone we'll see
about that
[Music]
the diversity of this marine life
it's a gift to us all
foreign
[Music]
this place is great
you can fix it up this is what we wanted
welcome home
this is Robert my husband it is so nice
to meet you Robert
yeah I guess I can see a resemblance
they look exactly like me
Robert I know you're new to these parts
[Music]
speak for everyone when I say you
already feel like one of us
[Music]
say it I was just hoping you might be
able to give me some more information
about it
you're wrong
you know I just found another painting
of him
everyone knows Robert okay listen you
you actually think that's you
[Music]
something is off
about this place
I swear it was the same guy in every
single one I would just take it as a
sign
you are
meant to be
neat do you understand me no go go
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
you have to look at you looking at me
[Music]
a video
foreign
foreign
doesn't lose sleep over the opinion of
sheep
[Music]
[Music]